this is a site-specific mural by the
artist Mya high up from her chemtrails
series it's a new collaboration between
the Wallach art gallery and the miller
theatre here specifically for the lobby
for the 2014-2015 school year I have
painted three murals in the lobby of the
miller theatre here at Columbia
University they are very loose patterned
works that are made with rollers when
Deborah first proposed that we work with
Maya Hayek to do the mural this year we
were super excited her work is just
amazing and seeing the vibrancy and the
many colors that she uses it's just it's
fantastic and we knew that it wouldnt
live in the space in a really exciting
way they're completely improvised and
they're very messy and drippy and kind
of sexy I think so we have a very strong
commitment to working with living
artists and young artists in particular
and so the fun and exciting part of
about working with Maya and
commissioning a visual artist is that we
have a whole years worth celebration of
the new work so the entirety of the year
is the world premiere performance of
this new work of art I think it's
interesting that there's such an
attention to get our outside of the
gallery space and that's one of the
interest for us and doing this in the
miller theatre is to bring it outside
the gallery you literally see it from
Broadway and it pulls you in especially
at night it glows so it just draws you
into all that's here on campus to see